[Music]
trick
his aggressive plays have been turning
heads since the game launched
but his rise to fame was nothing short
of a miracle
i overdrafted my bank account for
groceries and i cried in the car again
like that that was the lowest of my low
and now he wants to be more than just
another flashy frag artist
he wants to use his platform to help
others i'd never expected to be
where i'm at today and i just hung on i
just hung on
[Music]
hey everyone before we get into the
video i just want to let you all know
that we're going to discuss suicide and
suicidal ideation
so please be advised if you are dealing
with thoughts of self-harm then we've
put some links in the description below
that we hope can be helpful
before he was the most beloved most
aggro omen main invalorant
chris flexinja irvine jr was a pretty
normal kid
he was introduced to gaming by his older
brother at a young age but with five
siblings he always had to wait his turn
to get to the family pc to play games
like neopets and maplestory
we we'd all just play on this one
computer for a while and then uh
eventually we got our own computers i
was addicted to like runescape
league of legends and i've always been
addicted to like free-to-play fps
shooters i don't know why it's like the
free-to-play genre of shooters is like
my kind of thing
flex ninja fell in love with first
person shooters and that love inspired
him to share his gameplay online
he posted videos from games you have
never heard of stuff like
combat arms alliance of valiant arms and
black squad
flexinja didn't share his gameplay just
because it was fun for him though
he wanted to go bigger he was into
streamers like shroud
summit and joshua g and he wanted to be
like them
i loved their stream i loved the content
that they were making and i was like
i want that to be me one day i want to
be one of those
like streamers one day so but in those
early days
content creation was never more than a
hobby for flex ninja
what he really loved was athletics
he couldn't get enough of hiking
bouldering and eventually
even bridge jumping
but soon enough flex discovered his true
passion in life
the ultimate test for all of his
physical training in 2016 he started
competing in spartan races
we had one goal in mind when we started
spartan and it was to rip people off the
couch
a spartan race is a series of obstacle
races anywhere from 3 to 32 miles
usually taking place on mountainous
terrain competitors have to run crawl
jump and sometimes swim to get to the
end
and flexinja was hooked
but as much as he enjoyed spartan races
they didn't exactly love him back
the grueling physical competition was
taking a toll on his body and causing
him pain in his shoulders and knees
and by february 2017 those injuries led
to surgery
by the time he recovered he was still in
pain and his knees were
shot so about a year after the surgery
flexinja was forced to quit the sport he
loved
everything in my life at that point was
like just like [ __ ]
i just i remember um going to physical
therapy i went for like
a month and i couldn't afford any more i
sat in the parking lot
like looking at my bank account i like
50
left and i couldn't afford physical
therapy i just cried in my car
he fell into a deep depression and even
found it difficult to get out of bed
i texted my dad saying i was scared
because i had suicide notes on my phone
and
at that point like i just wanted it all
he started working for fedex but
nothing was making him happy at least
not until april 2019
when a new game reignited his passion
alright i'm going in the closed beta
launch of valrant came at the perfect
time for flex ninja the cartoony art
style reminded him of some of his
favorite childhood games but
not only that it gave him the spark he
needed and inspired him to return to one
of his former passions
content creation nice flex
his initial valorent youtube videos were
getting decent views for a smaller
channel
but then a few weeks later something
crazy happened
all of a sudden one of my omen videos
blew up and i got like
i got like 100k views like within 24
hours
flexing decided to go all in right then
and there
he quit his fedex job and devoted
himself to valorant content full time
hey what's up [ __ ] get it
two more one hp
[Music]
his aggressive omen clips were blowing
up on youtube and it wasn't long before
flex ninja was introduced to some
other fowler and one tricks not even on
it
no you can't do that flights the british
raise maine
and jonas the norwegian sova maine
joined forces with flex to become the
one trick trio
and together they watched as their
twitch and youtube channels blew
up me flights and like jonas we all just
like
connected flawlessly and yeah we became
the one trick trio because we all played
once uh agent i played omen flights
played reyes
jonas played soba and yeah and everyone
knows us for that
oh here we go here we go
flight send it
[Music]
kept getting bigger and bigger and
eventually he even signed with nrg
and even now a year after ballarat
launched everyone
still knows him as the original omen
main it's it's got me over 300k
subscriber uh
subs on youtube and it got me about 200k
followers on twitch so far
and it's just it's just crazy to think
that me
maining omen would get me this far and
like it's insane that like when people
think of omen in game they think of me
[Music]
but he wasn't just using his time in the
spotlight to show off his omen skills
flexinja opened up to his audience about
his own mental health struggles to try
to help destigmatize mental illness in
the gaming world
something that experts say can really
make a difference i think that these are
experiences that
gamers share right we all go through
this stuff and i think a lot of
um streamers and content creators are in
a unique position
to sort of share something publicly
using a platform that allows them to
connect with a lot of people
we all have those days where we feel
down and out but flex sinja wants to
make sure we remember to never give up
life turns around so fast like i am here
now
i'm super happy to be here i've talked
to i've talked about this in the past
like
in my stream and stuff just because like
i know people need to hear this right
now
and i think it's important getting that
message across like
just just why the weather the storm it's
gonna be shitty sometimes but like
i'd never expected to be where i'm at
today
and i just hung on i just hung on flex
is more than an omen one trick
gaming helped him fight depression and
make his dreams come true
but instead of just enjoying his
newfound fame he's making it a point to
help other people who
face the same challenges he has one day
at a time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages